[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream our 31st
i'm here with dr heather heing many many
things are afoot
including on this channel because we've
released a number of things
in sequence you may not get
notifications of them all based on the
vagaries of how youtube functions so
i will call your attention to them now
the black intellectual roundtable has
been
tremendously successful people are
really excited about it it has been
covered by the spectator
so check that out well worth a look i
have also just released
an interview with matt taibi which i
thought was great he has
long been someone i have admired and it
was an excellent conversation
um he endorsed unity 2020 which i
consider a very important bit of
progress
so anyway check those videos out oh and
the third one that we have recently
released
is an interview with the world's most
interesting orthodontist and i know that
doesn't sound like
i thought you called him the world's
most hated orthodoxy
he is absolutely hated is a more
interesting word than interesting okay
uh he is the the world's most hated
orthodontist and the thing is the only
people who hate orthodontists are people
like me who have been damaged by
orthodontists
and other orthodontists who don't want
the truth out about that kind of damage
so
anyway check out this podcast with um
dr mike mew and uh if you
are puzzling over how an orthodontist
could be interesting
you know think through that a little bit
and then check out what he uh what he
says on the dark horse because he is
truly a dark horse um
and uh and he doesn't appear to be hated
by his patients or by other patients
it's
it's within the field that he is
dismissed and disliked
dismissed and disliked and threatened
with the loss of his license and things
for saying
uh things that to me sound extremely
reasonable evolutionarily whereas
um mainstream orthodontia frequently
says things that are
evolutionarily preposterous about how
our genes have suddenly gone bad and
that's why teeth end up crooked and
things like this
yep that's what jeans do they suddenly
go rogue
suddenly go up they're on the fritz um
you're humming along hundreds of
millions of years
and then boom your jaw's all cattywompus
and you've got sleep apnea
and all that stuff yeah that's jeans for
you exactly
all right well that was good that was
sort of uh light on a day that i must
say has been
a bit heavy um because there's
there are things afoot on twitter which
in general when there are things afoot
on twitter
it is often best just simply to ignore
them but in this case i think there is
actual physical danger emerging from
them which
forces us to react to things um that we
might prefer not to
so in this case what i'm referring to is
what appears to be
an invitation from the majority report
with sam cedar delivered by a producer
for that program but
in making this invitation if that's
actually what it is
the producer in question uh
delivers knowing falsehoods about
me and these falsehoods look like
they will incite potentially violence
against
us and so you know we live here in
portland where things are quite tense
and there is
daily violence uh downtown and
basically this producer has made an
attempt to
portray me as somehow on the other side
so i have tweeted back and insisted that
the proper
remedies be taken that this be retracted
that we be given
an apology and that the producer in
question be fired because obviously
uh if he did this without the program's
knowledge
then this is a rogue producer
if you did it with the program's
knowledge then there's an even bigger
problem
so in any case we will see what they do
but i did want to
look at a what the
the libel in question is and then
pursue the actual truth behind it which
we can see because there's evidence so
the the particular claim that is being
made
is that i have been consulting for the
department of homeland security
now this claim is being hung on the fact
that i
have talked to an officer with the
department of homeland security which of
course
many of the viewers here will know
because i've talked about it openly here
there's no secret about it
in fact zach would you put up the uh
photo of the dhs officer
so that's not from my i sent it to you
um okay so we're going to try to get
that photo up for you
but in any case to remind people who did
hear the story and
um for people who were perhaps not here
for that episode
a department of homeland security
officer contacted me
saying that he wanted to tell me
his viewpoint about what he was seeing
it was in fact his last day
on the job as a dhs officer in portland
and so i went downtown and we had a
a conversation um and
anyway this is a while ago right i mean
this was this is before
um before the most recent um all right
so here is the officer in question
as you can see our meeting took place in
the open this is in the park
directly across from the uh the federal
buildings
in fact while we were talking we had a
conversation that
was an hour and a half possibly two
hours
a citizen journalist with
cop watch came over the officer knew him
they talked i was filmed by him with the
officer there was nothing
in the least bit secret about this and i
wasn't talking to him in any official
capacity
nor was it my instigation he wanted to
tell me things that he thought i needed
to know
so the idea that i am consulting for the
department of homeland security
is preposterous and
inflammatory in light of what dhs is
currently engaged in in downtown
portland
so for those of you who don't know that
story
what is apparently happening is the
department of homeland security
has unmarked vehicles rented vehicles
and it has what appear to be officers
who are not in uniform and what they
have been doing
is they have been grabbing people from
the crowd
during the and by the way these things
are falsely portrayed as protests
they are in fact nightly riots which
have gone on for something like 50
consecutive nights
so these un uh
these out of uniform officers are
pulling people out of the crowd without
apparently
arresting them and they are transporting
them somewhere which apparently is into
the federal buildings
and those people are then in one case at
least delivered their miranda rights and
then
in that same case released hours later
without any explanation of whether or
not they've been charged with anything
now i do think i know what's going on
here and of course as a citizen i find
this very troubling this does not sound
uh like a constitutional process
it sounds extra constitutional however i
would point out
that i was warning about this very
possibility
i have been warning about it for many
years but i warned about it specifically
in
june i think june 1st zach can you put
up that tweet
okay i say in this tweet i don't think
people understand the significance of
the president declaring antifa a
terrorist organization
the patriot act and provisions of the
ndaa of 2012
make this frightening because antifa is
informal it puts
all protesters in danger like declaring
them uncitizens
i want to fill that out and explain what
it was that i was concerned about
back on june 1st the term
terrorist is a magical term
it is a bit like the terms that we see
deployed
by the protest movement in the streets
where the terms have multiple meanings
and dodging between those meanings
allows things to take place that would
not be normal
that would not be possible with normal
terminology
so terrorist to me and in fact
if i recall correctly years ago before i
was in the public eye i wrote a piece
in the aftermath of the attacks in
france
about what terrorism is and why we are
reacting to it incorrectly
and the point of that piece was that
terrorism is basically
a psychological op it's just it's a
psyop and the idea is
a an enemy that does not have the power
to overwhelm you with force
can fool you by hijacking your
fight-or-flight response
it can fool you into doing more damage
to yourself than it would be capable of
doing directly that's what terrorism is
that's the
why terror is in the heart of that term
and so my point was
when somebody engages in a terrorist
attack you need to be very very careful
about your reaction because whatever
your instinct is to do may well not be
in your interest
it's like the allergic reaction to a bee
sting that is much worse than the
beasting itself and can actually cause
your death
so terrorism is about using
fear to get people to hurt themselves i
do not believe that that is an
accurate description of this protest
movement this protest movement is
wielding a threat but it is
not to me a terrorist threat it is
different and so the instinct to throw
every term that
suggests that it is awful at it
including terrorist is a problem
because the term terrorist triggers
changes in your rights
let me push back on that a little bit
and i'm not sure i'm i'm
out of my depth with regard to the legal
definitions of these various terms but
um given what you just said about what
terrorism does
your analogy was to uh the body's
inflammatory response
uh when a foreign toxin a foreign
substance comes in like a bee sting it's
the actual
body's response the the the
anti-inflammatory
no it's the inflammatory the immune
response that is inflammatory
um that is actually what kills you and
that this is how terrorism works as well
um whether or not that is the
method of action of antifa the
you know which is to say um maybe some
of those were originally protesters but
now many of them are rioters
um certainly that would appear to be the
mode by which
um they are getting so many people to
remain quiet
um i do not disagree that fear
is at the core of this but i think
actually this movement is delivering a
credible threat
inside of institutions it's not a so you
know in the case of let's say 911
3 000 americans were killed but then we
lost
more than twice that number in the
military response
in iraq and afghanistan and we spent
trillions of dollars
um you know in order to engage in those
responses and so the harm we did to
ourselves just
as a matter of fact was uh much larger
than the harm
that was done to us in this case i don't
think
it um uh it is the method of action in
other words the threat is credible it's
not uh
a a um it's not misleading
so i guess uh but maybe we're talking
about two different things
that um the threat on the streets is is
violent
yeah and is destructive of property and
in some cases um humans as well
uh the threat that is accompanying this
that predates this the critical race
theory and
bastardization of post-modernism and
white fragility
and all of this nonsense is actually
being
being wielded as a very blunt instrument
that
is in fact you know incredibly effective
oh it's incredibly effective so those i
mean those things aren't identical but
they are very much hand in hand
it's hard for most people to to separate
out those two things in fact
they shouldn't be separable when we try
to figure out you know
how do we move forward how how do we get
our democracy back
right here's the point though let's say
i'm wrong
okay about which about whether or not
this was a terrorist threat
so whether or not antifa is a terrorist
threat right
okay let's say i'm wrong still what side
of the issue am i on
i am trying to keep the federal
government from using the word
terrorist about this movement right now
i am
as troubled by this movement as anyone
right and that should be very clear to
anyone who has
watched this podcast however even as
troubled as i am
i do not want it labeled terrorist
because i know what happens next you
know what happens next
people get dragged off the street by
people out of uniform without their
rights being read
in unmarked cars and you know what it
gets worse from here because
chances are you don't know about the
ndaa
2012 and its two provisions right these
two provisions are so frightening and so
draconian
and frankly i've been through this right
you and i were part of occupy
right occupy was also declared a
terrorist organization
occupy there was nothing terrorist about
occupy right
it was just something that was a vile
stigma that was thrown at us that turned
out to have
these legal consequences and so let me
just run through a little bit of
what we're really dealing with here
in the aftermath of 9 11 there were many
changes made
to the structures that protect citizens
ndaa 2012 had two provisions
that resulted in i would argue the
elimination of all of your
constitutional rights with the exception
of your
third amendment right not to have
soldiers quartered in your house
and the reason that i say that is
because those provisions
allow the executive at the moment that's
donald trump
to declare someone terrorist and at the
point that you have been declared a
terrorist the federal government has the
right
to remove you from any
street in the world they have the right
to remove you you do not have the right
to review the evidence against you you
do not have the right to confront
witnesses you do not have the right to
cross-examine so
you can be disappeared under these
provisions
because you have been declared under
this special term
right so i believe what is happening in
the streets of portland
is that they are the federal government
is firing
across the bow of the protest movement
and they are alerting them
what provision they have now triggered
right now they are
basically involved in some kind of ndaa
catch and release program
which is vastly better than being
disappeared and having nobody
you know having lost your habeas corpus
rights but nonetheless it suggests
what legal landscape we have just
entered which is exactly what i was
warning about on june 1st with that
tweet
so if you are concerned about what is
going on in the streets of portland
please understand it what we have is a
situation
in which um our mayor who happens also
to be our police commissioner a
disastrous
structural error in uh civilian
governance
our mayor has coddled this movement for
years he has allowed them to take over
intersections to declare themselves the
police
he has kept the police out of their way
that has set up a dynamic over the last
50 days in
the heart of downtown portland in which
two
federal buildings have been under
persistent
attack every night with all sorts of
things including
incendiary fireworks and the police who
guard them
have been targeted with all sorts of
improvised weapons that include
really dangerous things like slingshots
with bbs
right think about how much damage you
can do to somebody if they're not
wearing
a helmet and you hit him with a bb from
a slingshot
so you've got this dynamic where the
mayor
refuses to enforce the law downtown
you have riots reliably happening every
night
the target is two federal buildings that
the federal government is charged with
defending
and now you have donald trump playing
politics with this situation
in which somebody does need to enforce
the law and if the city and the state
won't do it
then it makes sense that the federal
government at least as far as those
buildings go
will do it but what are they doing right
they're using this extremely draconian
stuff
that some of us challenge from the very
beginning
you know in fact if you think i'm
exaggerating of course the charge will
come back that my interpretation of the
ndaa
2012 is incorrect and that's not what it
means of course the language is
meant to be ambiguous but chris hedges
sued the obama administration over this
a federal court
declared that he had standing what was
the basis of that decision
that he had interviewed al-qaeda members
as a journalist and that that meant
he could be declared a terrorist and he
might be disappeared
so a federal court agreed that that was
true and then a three-judge panel
reversed the decision triggering this
law to be the law of the land
to restore it restored it to that status
and as far as i know it's the law of the
land today
what can you do about it well you could
challenge it in court
or if something happens to you there's
nothing that can be done
right you don't even have a legal avenue
because the very nature of these
provisions is to eliminate that legal
avenue
so we find ourselves in a terrible
position we have feeble
law enforcement as a result of a
political entity that is to say mayor
wheeler
and the governor refusing to enforce the
law which means that the only entity
that can enforce the law laws the
federal government
and you have the federal government
taking these abusive powers that it's
set aside for itself and using them
predictably because
we have invoked the word terrorist which
we never should have done and which i
tried to prevent so
if you think i'm on the side of dhs
violating the constitutional rights of
americans
you just don't understand where we are
and how we got here right
i tried to prevent that from happening
and so i absolutely insist
that the majority report correct the
record
retract what it has said issue an
apology and
fire this producer it seems to me that
at a minimum
those things are necessary
sorry all right that wasn't as funny as
i was hoping no no sorry i'm just i
don't
um i'm not sure what we should do next
um
one of the things that this producer who
you haven't named so
i don't know if that's intentional i
don't know if i'll name him then no
let's let's name him he's
uh i don't know how to pronounce it matt
letch i think
either they both work yeah um
that's that's not necessary what
um one of the things that he
says in this in this thread uh
is uh a i mean he's playing with words
of course you know he says you're
consulting with dhs
which at the point that either of us
says
for god's sake it's not consulting um
because consulting
obviously implies payment implies some
sort of
remuneration he'll say no consulting
means a totally different thing
also so there's there's clever word play
here
but one of these
tweets zack maybe you want to show this
now
says do not question brett weinstein's
sources on the ongoing portland race war
that he's consulting dhs about and it
has two pictures
uh one with you brett and me and andy
know from actually the day that we met
him that's
um the picture has clipped out helen
pluckrose this is at the
james de moore panel that peter pagozian
moderated
that james and helen and i
uh did with uh andy noe organizing
he was a student at psu at the time so
that was at portland state university in
february 2018
and then there's a second picture here
of uh you brett with andy
uh in portland i don't know maybe a year
later or so maybe it's some time last
year sometime in 20 yeah we had just
moved to portland and
andy asked if i wanted to see what was
going on at the protest and so
um i went to both the antifa side of the
protests
and the proud boys side of the protest
in order to observe them
both and anyway this is being portrayed
obviously
in a particular light so i mean it's you
know we met andy
on uh the day of that that left-hand
picture and uh we became friends
and um fact is we don't cherish politics
he doesn't share ours uh and we talk
about that um
when we see each other we don't see each
other very often but by as it happens i
actually did spend a couple of hours
with andy about a month ago
walking around outside um as one needs
to do now
and one's meeting people outside of
their home for the most part it happened
to be raining so we both ended up
totally drenched because like
good pacific northwesterners neither of
us had brought an umbrella
um and one of the things he asked me in
that conversation
from sometime mid-june i think was
uh does this look like a race war this
is like a race war to you and that's
exactly the language that this producer
from the
majority report is claiming
portland's ongoing race war to which i
say
[ __ ] this is not a race war and
that's what i and andy asked me that
question
in good faith he was wrestling with is
this a race war and i said
no i really don't think so um and you
know or or will this become a race war
are these race riots
and in part uh i think i think
not um but that is exactly what the
instigators want us to think
they are trying to pit us against one
another so
so you know boldly really
and so i will say here
um that we have a
i guess you don't have to show this zack
but um we'll post in the show notes
a half-hour-ish interview with a
black portland police officer he's not
nhs he's a portland police officer
in which um he is being asked what's
what's the experience what is the
experience on
the streets now and one of the things he
says
uh is quote this is a black police
officer
on the streets in portland who has been
out there um
on you know i don't probably not every
night but these these
protests that have become riots have
been taking place downtown and elsewhere
in portland now
uh consecutively for i think more than
50 nights now he says
it says something when you're at a black
lives matter protest and you have more
minorities in the police side
than in a violent crowd and you have
white people screaming at black officers
you have the biggest nose i've ever seen
now this man
was himself educated at psu he
appears to be a good and honorable
police officer
and he is he is angry he is
legitimately and justifiably angry
and one of the other things he says in
this interview there's a short version
that um that i tweeted a day or two ago
that i think you did as well but the
longer the full interview is is quite
compelling
and one of the things he says is
whenever i try to talk
to protesters when another person of
color comes up to me
and tries to talk immediately what
happens
is one of the white protesters comes and
tells them that all cops are bastards
and they can't talk to me
and he in fact relates a story anecdote
yes but he relates a story in which
a young i think it's black woman comes
up to him says why don't you talk to us
and he says to her if i try to talk to
you i will be stopped
some white protesters gonna come and
take and tell me you can't talk to me
and exactly as he's saying that exactly
this thing happens
and this this woman this this protester
woman of color says my god that's
exactly what he just said
what happened but it's it's it's
read-only this is this is read-only
activism read-only
variety and protests but this is also
exactly
what we saw at evergreen this is part of
the tactics and it's part of what makes
the overall strategy so successful
you will not take in new information so
this this isn't actually
about race we are being told it's about
race to divide us to keep those people
who can see it
who look like we're supposed to be the
ones feeling guilty and ashamed of the
color of our skin right now
from saying actually no i'm not racist
i do think that there are problems with
policing certainly historically and
still today
but that doesn't mean that i need to sit
down and shut up when i see
a divisive movement that is pretending
to be about race
create division in society no
so i i want to correct one thing what i
have said and what i believe
is that we are being headed towards a
race war
that fringes on both sides are actually
interested in such a thing
and that what is happening is that this
desire to categorize us by race
on the left is now being enforced
through all these institutions on to
everybody so it's going there
right now but it's not but it's not it's
not what it's not what the thing is on
the streets right obviously you don't
have a racism
told it is right but the point in the
black lives matter protests are mostly
white people
right but telling the black people to
shut up because they're not falling into
line it is white people
behaving as another one of these terms
with a double meaning right they are
behaving as what they are told
an ally behaves as which is being
synonymized with something
accomplice right as if that doesn't tell
you what the game is
and so the point is these white allies
and that's the wrong term because ally
is actually a symmetrical relationship
and this is a subordinate relationship
but these white allies
are enforcing this new orthodoxy which
is going to cause
white people to view themselves as an
entity
right so the race war is being set up we
are being played and we are going to be
driven
into this state and that's extremely
dangerous so that's that's exactly
it is being set up we are being informed
that this is about race
and therefore those of us who are
historically on the wrong side of this
issue
even though um well just put put
put that aside you know you know our our
ancestors
actually uh weren't weren't part of that
right yeah um cert certainly you're none
of yours were in any way
right you know my ancestors were being
persecuted in europe
right um so yeah uh
but we are being told it's about race
and that is going to make it become
about race and it's going to bring out
the worst it's it already i hope it's
brought out the worst
of the pseudo left but it's going it's
about to bring out the worst of the
pseudo right it's gonna bring out the
[ __ ] fringe lunatics on both sides
and there you have it you know there
you'll have your race war
right and so um the thing is what we
tried to explain
um several times in the past is that
the thing that is special about the us
is that it aspires to be something
different than this
historically speaking lineage is battle
that's been standard and all of the
worst atrocities in history owe to this
way of viewing things or at least almost
all of them
what we have now is the resurrection of
that viewpoint
which is the uninvention of
the american attempt to put those things
aside and for us to collaborate as one
people
in spite of our lineage level
differences so this is a very
un-american uh instinct but
the problem is it has an advantage
america aspires to do this thing which
requires us to construct a different
structure we never got it right but we
were headed in the right direction
we made great progress on it i do
believe that progress stalled which is
part of why people are so angry
but going in the other direction is
completely incoherent it is the most
foolish thing you could do and that's
before you get to the consequences that
this will have
internationally which is to say if we
hobble ourselves by
battling lineage against lineage within
the u.s
we are going to take our position in the
world and we are going to undermine it
and what that's going to do
at the very least is it's going to
empower china
china which at this very moment is
behaved in stuff that
frankly uh the parallel you know as we
are doing things at least some on the
left are doing things that look maoist
and it's having
exactly the expected consequence the
former maoists are now doing stuff that
looks nazi
right they have concentration camps full
of people
organ harvesting i mean this is really
you know it's not
it's it's not goose stepping right is
that supposed to be the difference but
other than that it really looks like the
same phenomenon
and so as we hobble ourselves we are
going to empower
this uh this chinese entity which has a
race first view of the world and is
showing us
how it thinks that should be dealt with
so this this couldn't be more foolish
yeah all right again this is not the
most lighthearted
darkwurst podcast ever but i guess we
just have to deal with it
um so uh is there more to say on that
topic or should we move on to another
there's infinitely more but if you would
like to move on let's do so
all right uh so what's next uh harper's
letter as you like
all right so let's talk a little bit
about harper's letter harper's letter
emerged
two weeks ago something like that i
have not i i don't know the harpers
letter i don't know uh
caused a bit of a stir online and quite
a bit of backlash
and um it is
worth thinking about a little bit we
didn't get to it in our last
podcast but in any case what it does is
it groups
a number of people it was written by
five people um it's thomas chapter seven
it looks like
july seven thomas chatterton williams is
the most
prominent spokesman for the letter
but it's been signed by 100
plus people many of whom are
friends of ours from the long battle for
civil liberties that we've been involved
in
but in any case it's also got you know
big names
um on the left in particular um
who you know we we have not yet come to
meet um
but people like kathy paulett and uh jk
rowling
um and i'm just looking down the list
really
quickly oh salman rushdie um so you know
a lot it's it's
it's quite it's quite an impressive list
of signatories
yeah which is part of the problem with
it so
uh you want to show the you want to
scroll up and show the letter
you want me to scroll up and you want
zach to show the letter yeah yeah there
we go
so here's the letter for some reason
harper's
debuted this to great fanfare online but
they're not going to publish it
on paper until october for some reason
that's a conspicuous
oddity about it but in any case as i see
it the problem with the letter
is that it is incredibly tepid with
respect
sorry but um you know it's presumably
it's going on
it's going into the um hard copy
magazine in october because that's right
before the election i mean that's that's
what that timing is about you know
they're going to say something about the
timing of how long it takes to get
things into print and all of this but
okay
it's also you know just it's this isn't
an october surprise but it's
you know it's it's trying to be
something like that so
let's talk about what the problems are
one it is an incredibly
tepid defense of freedom of expression
and two it is divisive
twice over the letter goes to great
pains to
to portray the problem of sensoriousness
as a right wing problem at a moment when
in fact
the right wing contains many people who
have been courageous in our defense for
example
while the left or the mainstream left
was feeding us to the wolves and so
at this moment in history to say that
actually the problem
that free speech faces a problem it
comes from the right but in this case
we're seeing hints of it on the left
it's just simply not accurate and it is
unkind to people who have been
courageous
in the defense of people across the
aisle like us so for example
robbie george has been very courageous
in
in our defense you can see his testimony
and oh maybe you can't see it because
at the point the democrats took over the
house they eliminated the video
in which he testified on the same panel
that i was on
if anybody has that video i'd like it um
we
had it but i can't locate it in any case
he defended us he is uh right of center
and he deserves to be recognized for
that rather than to be portrayed as part
of the
the political spectrum that doesn't
understand the value of these rights
so the letter takes great pains to
portray the
right as the problem to suggest that the
left is beginning to show signs which is
not true the left has
a massive problem with these civil
liberties
at the moment and then the letter
divides a second time by
bringing certain people into the list of
signatories and not inviting others
so there are many of us on the left who
never saw the letter until it emerged we
were surprised at its existence
now if you and i had been asked um
i don't i am sure i would not have
signed it and i believe what i would
have done
is i would have responded that there was
a lot wrong with the text of the letter
and i would have tried to get them
to correct it and i don't know whether
that would have had any
success or not but what i do know
is that we were specifically not asked
while people like
matt iglesias are prominently featured
in the list of signatories so
we weren't asked i know that sam harris
wasn't asked and so
consider the following puzzle sam harris
has been absolutely courageous and
steadfast in his defense
of free expression the free exchange of
ideas
matt iglesias has been on the wrong side
of this issue until the last
few weeks when he has finally apparently
woken up
now i would say welcome to him if he's
finally gotten it
but to sideline somebody like sam harris
as you bring matt iglesias into what
appears to many to be the forefront of
this battle is preposterous
for one thing it makes an implication
about why sam isn't there
i know from talking to a number of the
people on the list that they did not
know who was to be asked and who wasn't
to be asked so the absence of
sam harris could mean he uh refused to
sign
it could mean that there's something
about sam harris
that makes him an inappropriate person
to be asked
and the thing is i believe many people
have that sense but where did they get
it
they got it from people like matt
iglesias so to have
the uh the press portray
people like sam as somehow beyond the
pale to stigmatize them
and then for this letter to exclude them
on the basis that that stigma makes them
controversial when really all they were
doing
was defending the most central rights
that we ought to
all be defending is
the height of lunacy so in any case the
letter
um is troubling i believe we ought to be
troubled by it
and just to say one final thing
to bring all of these important voices
including thomas chatterton williams
including jonathan height
barry weiss uh to bring them all on as
signatories
to a letter that then divides us twice
over
has compromised the movement to protect
these civil liberties rather than
enhanced it and that's
that's why i'm upset about it
and in the final paragraph it's a short
letter but in the final of three i think
paragraphs
one sentence is the way to defeat bad
ideas is by exposure argument persuasion
not by trying to silence or wish them
away
sure of course the next sentence we
refuse any false choice between justice
and freedom which cannot exist without
each other so
that's worth that's worth a little
exploration isn't it
the the far left would
actually um you know publicly mock the
idea of caring about freedom because
justice is
the preeminent value and the far right
tends to hold quite the inverse right uh
inverse values that
uh freedom is paramount and uh justice
not be damned but
justice will suffer at the hands of
freedom and so we have
um to some degree to the degree that the
uh the polls the left-right polls in
politics are coherent
you do have people sliding the trade-off
for
you know increasing justice at some
small cost of freedom on the left and
people sliding
to you know increase freedom at some
small cost to justice on the right
um but this suggests that there's
that pointing that out as a choice
that as if they as if justice and
freedom are in trade-off relationship
with one another
is false and that's that's facile
that actually doesn't have much
representation in the world well i'm not
i guess i'm not sure exactly what you're
saying there is a trade-off relationship
but the idea
that one needs to choose you know is
obviously incorrect the question is
where's the sweet spot and
um you know what was the genesis of this
letter relative to those things and
you know well so it's possible that they
mean to say that there are people on the
right who want
freedom and no justice i don't i've
actually never even heard that
caricature
right i've never heard the caricature of
the people on
on the left they want no freedom they're
you know
the the far left or the people on the
right want want no justice
so that would be a character that i
don't think is what they're engaging in
so if i read this
with a little bit more more care
less desire to caricature uh the
intention here
the idea that there's that there's never
a choice
is is is wrong actually because they
aren't trade off with one another and it
seems to me that this letter
is misunderstanding that point
which is in fact i think a point that is
misunderstood across the spectrum across
the political spectrum
um but particularly likely to be
misunderstood
in sort of uh leftish-wing
intellectual circles the idea of
tradeoffs being
a not a desirable but a
a reality of the human experience and of
the just the world
that you can't get around no matter how
much you don't like it yeah they're a
design constraint
and you know we can have endless uh
arguments about which thing is more
important but the answer is how do you
find the sweet spot in which you give up
you know a small amount of justice for
freedom and a small amount of freedom
for justice rather than keep pushing the
slider around and
suffering the catastrophes that result
so i mean maybe i'm reading too much
into this and it's just you know it's a
short letter and there
you know with with two more sentences
there could have been nuance that was
that was clear here but i just i do
think that that
that reveals again uh the
the bias of the letter which would slate
anyone
who is right of some line that is
ever more difficult to draw um as
not just a conservative and not just
maybe a republican but someone who is
working with the forces of a liberalism
and you know that's it's not it's not a
fair characterization
well and in some sense i don't think
this is designed to be a fair
characterization
what i have the sense has happened is
that a bunch of people who
and i must say um in some sense i'm
borrowing heavily here from
from eric the
journalists seem to have some kind of a
carve out where things that were
happening
[Music]
on campus were understood to be a
separate phenomenon and journalists
portrayed them as unimportant because
they did not understand that they would
be in the line of fire
soon enough and so having suddenly found
themselves in the line of fire
you can read matt tybee's piece on this
and you can discover how
all of these important newsrooms
including places that you would expect
to be most immune
like for example the intercept are
having these horizontal
uh revolutions take place inside of them
so as that's coming for journalists and
they are suddenly
discovering that they don't have the
safety that they thought they had that
that was that
their appeasement is resulting in a
predictable outcome where they're now
suddenly being targeted
there's a desire to carve out some sort
of new agreement and that new agreement
is you know why is the letter so
deferential
to um the left which frankly has done a
terrible job
of policing these challenges to the free
exchange of ideas
well in part because what this really is
is a negotiation
but i don't think jonathan height would
be negotiating i think jonathan height
and i'm just using him as an example of
an important voice who i believe has
been brought into this under somewhat
false pretenses
but you know the the thing that needed
to happen was a statement
in which first of all everybody who had
properly defended these rights
was invited on and b that didn't divide
us further thereby
by um hobbling the effort um to fight
the censorious
instincts but uh what ended up happening
is the attempt to negotiate some sort of
agreement that would again give
these journalists and academics some
kind of
immunity from what's moving across
society
has now taken the voices that were
clearest and put them in this
compromised context
so um i think it's frankly it's
it's very unfortunate that it's happened
and we need to be very careful
that it doesn't happen again because all
sorts of people are going to discover
they're suddenly in the line of fire and
they're going to attempt to
carve something out and lots of people
are going to look at it and say well
i'm in favor of free expression of ideas
therefore i should sign on to everything
that comes my way that points in that
direction but the point is no no
sign on to the ones that are right don't
sign on to the ones where somebody's
trying to accomplish something
and they put it loosely in the terms of
free expression of ideas and so
you know it's in the ballpark because
the in the ballpark stuff is not
it's not uh refined enough to be useful
it's going to do exactly the opposite
thing
yeah what do you have next
uh let's see oh do we want to talk about
the um the transcripts that emerged
um i guess it would be about a week ago
i don't know when when they emerged i
know what you're talking about so what
you're talking about
is the transcripts from the body cams of
two i believe of the police officers
uh in the george floyd killing
so uh do you want me to set this up or
do you want to do it i don't
you just showed it to me for the first
time so i've read them but that's about
as far
as i've got okay you want to scroll up
and just show what document we're
talking about uh yeah
it's a long document um so zach you can
now
show us um this was
um an 82 page document which is two
different
body cam transcripts filed in district
court
in minnesota ten days ago or so actually
same day the harper setter came out
looks like um
and yeah it's it's audio transcripts
from
two of the police officers involved and
what i
what i was able to do i read through
them and went back and looked at a
little bit of the video and was able to
map on
um a little bit in one of the cases to
sort of where in the transcript
um we're seeing because it's it's hard
to know
without any sound or anything it's hard
to know what is actually going on when
yeah in this transcript
but what what what do you see here well
i see a number of things so
first of all this covers a lot of
territory that i spoke to joe rogan
about that we
disagreed over the interpretation of it
so now we know a lot of the answers that
we were speculating on
um back then and i will just say i've
read through the transcript and
certain things one there's no indication
that
uh chauvin and floyd recognized that
they knew each other if they knew each
other at all right so there's no
dialogue between them that seems like
people who know each other
i don't see anything in there about race
there's no
overt racism in the transcript doesn't
mean it's not there on people's minds
but
it doesn't show up there excited
delirium does show up but it shows up
late in the interaction
so probably doesn't play a role as
important as i suspected it might
i wasn't able to figure out um early
throughout the interaction floyd is
saying things like about claustrophobia
um
i'm choking i can't breathe before
i as far as i can tell before um any
officers
are on him and he says things like my
face is gone
and um and then what you can't
hear in the video that we all saw but
you see in these transcripts this
discussion between
officers um is you know is he
intoxicated what kind of pipe was that
do we think it's pcp
yeah um and um what what what you see
again is no
no mention of race um between
the officers at least from these two
transcripts um but what does appear to
be a description uh
a discussion of them trying to figure
out what is going on with this guy
and how it is that they can do what they
need to do
it seems like while really trying not to
hurt him
well look i i'm no expert in the police
stuff but i do want to say
in the transcript it is clear a that
george floyd complains about not being
able to breathe before he's on the
ground
b that the officers don't prefer to put
him on the ground they want to put him
in the car
he won't go and actually he asks to be
put on the ground
right so i you've said that i didn't i
didn't see that in these transcripts and
i read through it fast but um
you know so floyd talks about
um you know this just happened to me um
i don't want to get shot
and you know there's a whole lot in in
what he says that we can imagine and you
know i
i just simply don't know the truth of
his of his history but we could
certainly imagine
that he is beyond spooked by the
prospect
of agreeing to demands by police when
he uh he doesn't disagree when they say
that he's passed a fake bell i guess is
why they were called to the scene but
that doesn't mean just because he did
either nothing wrong to begin with or
something trivial wrong that doesn't
mean
that something bad won't happen to him
so you know is he legitimately
you know worried and alarmed and saying
things that are incoherent
maybe but he's also so incoherent and so
unwilling to
respond to uh what appear to be very
moderate requests um that
uh that they're the police are being
pushed and pushed and pushed
well i don't know they want to put him
in the car yeah um he doesn't want to go
in the car he wants to go on the ground
and why do they want to put him in the
car
for having passed a fake bill well i
don't know yeah i don't know
you know i don't know enough about the
law i mean obviously passing a fake bill
you know potentially we're talking about
a counterfeiter
right obviously a 20 bill is not a major
matter but counterfeiting is a federal
crime i don't know i don't pretend to
know but
um but the point is
i mean i think the real point is this
the transcript
is complex right there are lots of
things in play here what we all saw on
video
was very troubling but
what it actually means is unclear
right what you need in order to figure
out what it means is
a court that is free to engage in
navigating those issues to have experts
on
the law on normal police procedure on
procedure under special circumstances on
the drugs that appear to have been in
his system and whether or not they were
present at the moment that he was being
arrested or this was a trace toxicity as
joe rogan suggests it might be you want
to know those things and you want to
have a court free to navigate these
things but
above and beyond the fact that the
transcript does reflect
a an environment that has a lot of
things going on in which a court would
need to navigate
here's the thing that is most troubling
to me that
link to the document was sent to me by a
friend
right we both thought it did not exist
in the world
on trying to figure out if the document
was authentic
it was on a new york times server right
and so the question is well
is it authentic why is it on a new york
times survey it became quickly apparent
that it had been published a couple days
prior
by the new york times they had written a
story on it
and they had linked the document and it
was sitting there on their server so it
is legitimate
but here's the question why was it not a
huge story
why was given all that is happening
downstream
of george floyd's tragic death why
was the contents of the transcript
not on everybody's mind because many of
the things that have been said about the
arrest
are i don't want to say testable in a
scientific sense but they can be
compared to the transcript and we can
actually have answers about what took
place
and there seemed to be very little
interest
in having that discussion
for some reason and it's very hard for
me to imagine i would have thought
uh the emergence of that transcript
would immediately have
trended on twitter it would have been
the focus of the news cycle for
24 hours if not more and there would
have been all kinds of discussion and
instead
somehow the social environment i think
treated it
as not important and i worry that it
treated as not important because it was
complex rather than
a simple story of murder yeah it is
complex
uh i've got i've got a piece highlighted
here
uh in which the officer is trying
to officer lane i guess in this case is
trying to get
uh floyd to get out of the car and um
we can't necessarily tell it looks like
he's
um floyd doesn't want to do it and he's
not doing it and the officer keeps
saying get out of the car
and the woman who he's with shavonna
renee hill finally says stop resisting
floyd
and this is this is early in the
interaction but you know one of one of
the people whom floyd is with
is reading what is happening as floyd
resisting
the officers um what appear
you know i'm i'm reading into this but
it would appear from her comment here
that she is reading what her
friend acquaintance whatever floyd is
doing as
resistance that is not warranted by the
situation
um it's it's complex like you said yeah
it's complex which doesn't mean it's not
murder but
you know again we have a structure that
deals with this it's called a court
it makes findings of fact and findings
of law it does so on the basis
of evidence and what we now
have is a situation in which the
public perception that it knows what it
saw on that video that that is
sufficient
to determine what took place is
uh it's a grave danger you know
it is a grave danger to our system to
the extent that what we end up doing
is using our courts to validate public
perception
basically getting them to rubber-stamp
the court of public opinions
judgment that is again the uninvention
of america
if if this is clear then allow it to be
found so in a court rather than
assuming that the court has only one
choice because the answer is so simple
can we do something a little hopeful all
right good yeah um
so there's a relatively new
magazine out of philadelphia called root
quarterly
uh it's an arts and ideas magazine so
it's called root quarterly art and ideas
from philadelphia and we became aware of
it
because the editor-in-chief i believe um
turns out to be a friend of your cousin
um ally whose wedding we went to last
year uh
and and she the editor
uh saw a picture of ali with eric
and went oh my worlds are colliding i
had i hadn't
had no idea and so um so they sent us
this is this is
almost a brand new magazine there's
there's four issues and it is
it is gorgeous and whether or not you're
in philadelphia i actually i want to
highly recommend it
as a it's you know it's a glossy a
glossy aesthetically
beautiful magazine that puts
uh that has art that has poetry that has
fiction
that has cultural critique and is just
open to ideas across the board and so
maybe just a couple couple things uh
from it
uh she heather uh heather shane
blakesley who is the publisher and
editor-in-chief of root quarterly
says in her summer uh letter uh which
came with the fourth
issue ever when i look back on the
pieces in the magazine i'm amazed at
what we've asked ourselves
so these are just some of the some of
the topics that they've explored and
four issues what does it mean to have
lost your way in your life
what does grace mean to you in what ways
are we manipulated by our media
must our identity be centered on our
race only especially if one is adopted
and does not know one's history and if
people will
in any case see us how they will what
does it mean to be an artist
mother and entrepreneur do the stories
we tell ourselves about our trauma
affect our well-being
can we entirely change careers and deal
with adult bullying at sixty
what does it mean to be a successful
professional but to not be able to share
your chronic pain with others as you
suffer
what do we lose when we cancel art or
artists what is the hell of being a
midwife who has undergone multiple
miscarriages
what does resilience mean to a person
recovered from addiction what kind of
country do we want to live in
so i've now read parts of the four
issues that she sent to us and they're
they're just they're they're
glorious and this this is exactly what
we need right now and it looks it looks
like they're actually surviving but i'd
love for us to
to help them survive it's called root
quarterly and
um from from again
uh heather shane blakesley's uh initial
essay in the initial issue
the very end she says the constant state
of hurt
of fear and of rage stoked by ever more
divided media and entrenched ideology
is a perfect breeding ground for further
division and for the type of widespread
addiction we now see in the united
states
thousands keeping the pain at bay on the
streets of philadelphia hundreds of
thousands across the country
an army of walking dead shuffling around
us with no spiritual tether
stripped of hope and humanity
and then there are the larger hordes all
of us are addicted to the glowing
rectangles of various sizes
crawling with spiders and bots
algorithms sucking us drive information
the feedback loop of ads and curated
content meant to move us in this
direction or that
a little more to the right a little to
the left a little more lonely
and deeper in debt it is social media's
job to numb us and addict us exploit our
worst instincts in most base biology
rather than give us anything that might
actually heal us
unite us with facts or strengthen our
ability to reason and live peacefully
with one another
we are animals and they have trained us
however we can be untrained to tune into
interesting ideas and honest
disagreement
to contemplate art that illuminates our
complicated humanity
to see our city in a new light to enjoy
our rootedness in our community
to that end we offer you unplugged pages
pressed with ink
which you hold in your hands right now
so we we can do this we we can still do
this
this is this is our better angels and we
owe it to
ourselves and all of us and our future
too to engage with art and with science
and with truth and with beauty with
honor and without division
yeah i heard in there uh i think the
central question
what country do we want to live in what
kind of country
and the thing is if you just play out
these alternatives you know tear it down
race first
it doesn't lead anywhere that you would
want to exist and it you know
frankly it's not it's not going to be
good for the people who are advocating
it either it's not good for any of us
so i i tweeted this thing which i got
some pushback on which i want to
defend here briefly okay um that
basically we are all in this together
and that our enemies
are the ones who don't know it now i
don't mean to put anybody in the enemy
category i would like nobody to be there
but i think
what is hard for people to grasp
is that actually what we have is very
fragile
it can come apart and that those who
treat it casually or hostily are putting
everyone in jeopardy the recognition
that actually we are
all dependent on features of the system
even those of us who are being unfairly
treated by the system are dependent on
that system
and therefore the only option we have
that is rational
is to make it work to the extent that it
has never worked for some populations
that
has to be fixed that's part of its
fragility but
tearing it down in the hope that
something great will emerge
is the road to madness so
um somehow we need to bring everybody on
board with the idea
that yes there are problems they have to
be addressed but
tearing the system down is it's like uh
sabotaging the ship on which you are
dependent
we're probably at about an hour do you
want to do you want to
uh say something about unity 2020 which
seems like a decent segue from what you
just said
yes well sure of course i do um so unity
2020
is moving forward we have um
big plans that will emerge very quickly
we are working on the technical aspects
of those plans
so that we can deploy them they will
involve you they are active
um so please come visit us at articles
of unity
um on twitter there's also a terrific
new animation that
that came out this week yeah great new
animation by
a true patriot who is like everybody
else involved
is volunteering his time he does great
work and it's beautiful
um so check out the animation you can
find that at our our twitter
page articles of unity i have also
tweeted it you could find it there
it's on our youtube channel which um is
uh going to be somewhat difficult to
find until youtube figures out what it
is
but in any case check out the animation
we're including afterwards
depending right yeah defending is
exactly right
um so there's a lot happening um
we uh we welcome matt tybee's
endorsement we know that there are
others waiting in the wings
who have not yet come out publicly but
are planning it
so this is all very exciting um you
should stay put we will be back in 15
minutes to do our
q a um do you want to say some things
yup so we'll we'll be answering your
super chat questions uh
in the next q a those that came in some
of those that came in this hour and some
of them that will be coming in next hour
um a week from tomorrow we'll be doing
our second private q a
for dark horse members which involves
signing up at my patreon at the 5
or up level um there is
also a private discord server that's now
available as a benefit at both of our
patreons
at that same five dollar up level and uh
reports are that it's really
going quite quite beautifully that this
is um
that this is a community uh that knows
how to talk to one another
even when they don't agree and that's
that's exactly what we are hoping to be
able to
facilitate uh anything else nope i think
that's it
like subscribe comment stick around
we'll see in 15 minutes
[Music]
you